mais dieu merci à vous tous d'être
présents pour la conférence de presse du
film the expendables 2 unités
spécialisées versailles man ouest c'est
avec un grand honneur et un grand
plaisir que je vous demande d'accueillir
à mes côtés une partie de l'équipe du
film partie du casting à commencer par
monsieur dolph lundgren
arnold schwarzenegger
ainsi que le comédien jean claude van
damme
mais ceci reste un stallone
voilà je vous propose de débuter dès
maintenant avec une première question
dans la salle madame bonjour
vu le casting impressionnant du film qui
réunit les meilleurs du genre ce film
c'est un petit peu pour vous comme une
finale des jeux olympiques
on voulait savoir si justement sur le
plateau vous avez ressenti une sorte de
compétition entre vous une volonté
particulière des pâtes et les autres
castings de mauvaises
de
natcho
nos
jours sauf
faute fort
simpson nous dit que à vrai dire pendant
tournage moi même je les encourage et à
ses pattes et un peu les uns les autres
à encourager cet esprit de compétition
qui existe de toute façon parce que il
nous dit toutes les personnes que vous
voyez ici les personnes qui sont dans
films sont des athlète naturellement
qu'ils ont cet esprit de compétition
déjà en eux et donc quelque part dans
leur vie privée également c'est quelque
chose qui est qui est très présent dans
leur comportement et dans l'eure dans
leurs habitudes donc et puis c'est vrai
nous dit il que on sait tous qu'on a
beaucoup de chance d'être des acteurs de
ce genre de films de faire ce genre de
film c'est une c'est une vraie chance
donc moi même encore une fois pendant le
tournage je les encourager à aller dans
ce sens là et asos à se monter un peu
les uns les autres pour pouvoir donner
le meilleur d'eux mêmes sur l'écran
une autre question
est à l'honneur ce
week-end
et chose
dès 9 heures
from dust de queen
weezer
group risk of the soul blues et life de
fermer fortement les efforts
des work devait s'appeler désastre la 3d
nos deux rixes paintball
estate reit cause noble
mais
une question était pour monsieur
stallone
7,7 d'un musical à bout comme une fille
mais la question c'est est mais en même
temps dans le film tous les personnages
que vous jouez que vous interprétez à
l'écran eh bien ils peuvent démonter une
bombe nucléaire très facilement par
contre parler avec une femme c'est déjà
beaucoup plus difficile et pourquoi
c'était important de montrer cette
espèce de faiblesse qu'ils ont par
rapport à la femme dans le film et
sylvester stallone lui dit que qu'une
femme de toute façon c'est quelque chose
c'est quelqu'un en sait quelque chose de
beaucoup plus compliqué qu'une arme
nucléaire et quelque part ça montre leur
ce petit côté
papa sûr de pas forcément à l'aise dans
ce genre de situation et lorsqu'ils sont
en groupe lorsque tous et tous ces
personnages que l'on va en films se font
partie d'un groupe ça marche ça
fonctionne mais en même temps lorsqu'on
regarde leur vie privée leur vie
familiale leur vie leur mariage et bien
c'est un désastre absolu il ya
absolument tout va mal tout et tout est
assez désastreux est vraiment tout ne
fonctionne que lorsqu'ils sont encore
une fois dans cet esprit d'équipé
et quelque part cela renforce aussi ce
côté expendable c'est à dire le fait
qu'on puisse entre guillemets se
débarrasser d'eux facilement eh bien ça
renforce le côté esprit d'équipé ça
explique en quelque sorte aussi toutes
ces difficultés qu'ils ont dans leur vie
dans leur vie quotidienne et or et
intime une autre question dans la salle
monsieur ici les premières et par après
j'ai une question générale pour pour les
4 quelle est leur définition du héros et
du guerrier qui est peut-être là même où
pas
accédé scotian gosford for you what is
your own definition of the
world
as we want to
be oui ma bulle elles sont une mode je
serai grand mère n aura été qu est sorti
dans le soap à ford est son plus beau eu
besoin de me retirer de cause gwen
giabbani comme une simple loi de life is
going to go
ce modèle mixte pas assez beau
afin d'être de mauvais
goût
la
situation
de
défaut le calcio wright sommet nicolas
dufour god
game il sait
exactement qui serait drôle
si on nous dit que
jean
michaud
du 15
mai manif en demi dose special magic me
gave un magic mountain la 40 cède
1,12 special moves to gif
china
again non ma définition
et se gare ou believe in to something
good causse ivandry fisc et
even bigger
and protect
nous dit que pour lui un héros sa
définition du héros c'est quelqu'un qui
qu'il sent que qu'il a le devoir de deux
des trente mètres en compétition tout
simplement être en compétition justement
pour pour aller contre cette espèce de
sensations parfois que l'on peut avoir
que tout le monde peut avoir de ne
servir à rien de ne pas avoir vraiment
de d'utilité profonde et bien pour un
port pour aller au delà de ça ils vont
faire quelque chose d'héroïque de
manière à être
que d'autres puissent se souvenir de ces
passé plat pas comme pato que quelqu'un
de quelqu'un comme ça dans la rue
quelqu'un de régulier de u2 keane qui ne
vaut rien mais quelqu'un qui a vraiment
fait quelque chose pour pour changer
quelque chose quelque chose de profond
et c'est la raison pour laquelle vieilli
sans aucun doute beaucoup de gens
s'engagent dans l'armée beaucoup de gens
deviennent militaires pour pouvoir
vraiment accomplir quelque chose qui
aille au delà de ce que la vie peut vous
offrir au départ pour lui c'est ça la
définition du héros arnold
schwarzenegger répond rebondi là dessus
en disant que 1 euro pour lui c'est
quelqu'un qui fait de quelque chose
d'impossible quelque chose de possible
pour lui c'est vraiment c'est à ce
moment là qu'on se rend compte qu'il a
réalisé quelque chose d'héroïque au sens
large du terme il prend l'exemple
notamment de nelson mandela qui a dit
que beaucoup de choses peuvent paraître
impossible et sont décrites comme étant
impossible à faire jusqu'à ce que
quelqu'un le fasse et ça quelque part
c'est c'est aussi un challenge c'est un
challenge qui peut être un challenge
politique par exemple il y avait
certaines décisions politiques les
résultats qu'on doit obtenir qui
paraissent absolument impossible à
obtenir et que certaines personnes
obtiennent justement tout simplement
parce qu'elles ont essayé qu'elles ont
réussi à le faire mais ça marche
également sa ce genre de réflexion peut
également s'adapter au monde du sport au
nom de la science au monde du cinéma
bien évidemment et c'est vrai que il y à
différents types de héros et aujourd'hui
nous dit arnold schwarznegger
aujourd'hui on n'est pas évidemment là
pour parler politique etc on est là pour
parler d'un film donc de dinde un
spectacle et voilà lorsqu'on revient au
genre cinématographique et lorsqu'on
parle des héros dans cet esprit là il y
a beaucoup de héros et la manière dont
on se rend compte que ce sont des héros
bien par exemple il ya un an et demi un
vilain un méchant dans le film et ce
méchant cet ennemi on a l'impression
qu'il est impossible à battre qu'il est
absolument impossible il est invincible
et le héros sont son but à ce moment là
c'est d'arriver à le combattre et
d'arriver à le vaincre et à ce moment là
il a fait quelque chose d'héroïque et
aux yeux des spectateurs voilà c'est le
héros c'est lui qui devient le héros et
puis c'est aussi des personnes qui tout
simplement risquent leur vie alors ils
peuvent risquer leur vie pour beaucoup
de choses pour leur famille pour une
cause pour pour plein de choses mais le
grand avantage aussi dans le film que
que c'est que ces comédiens sont venus
défendre aujourd'hui est bien c'est que
par rapport à tout ça par rapport à
toutes ces tous ces thèmes dont nous
venons par les l'héroïsme le combat il a
également quelque chose de très
important c'est l'humour et l'humour
c'est quelque chose que sylvester
stallone fait de manière très très
efficace tout simplement pour commencer
parce qu'il connaît très bien les
comédiens avec lesquels il a joué il a
décidé de ne pas les faire voir
uniquement ceux leur côté très fortes
réserves très brave extrême est
également très drôle et il y as et
c'était d'ailleurs un challenge très
important pour sylvester stallone parce
que lorsque l'on voit tous les tous les
comédiens qui sont ici par exemple de
plein de graines dans schengen c'est
quelqu'un on le voit qui est très
sérieux qui est très
qui est très qui est très sérieux qui
est très très efficace mais c'est
également quelqu'un de très très drôle
et ça les gens qu'ils connaissent ils
connaissent bien le savent le savent
qu'il est drôle mais pour pouvoir le
rendre à l'écran de manière subtile et
en même temps qui fonctionne qui
marchent que les gens comprennent et
capte immédiatement c'est un vrai
travail de réalisateur que sylvester
stallone odierno de schwarzenegger a
vraiment très bien fait
et quelque part il espère également que
le public saura voir et est décelé dans
chacun des comédiens 7 ce côté drôle
grâce grâce aux scénarios notamment
écrit par sylvester stallone et grâce à
tous ces petits moments très drôles qui
font que le film peut être compris et
interprété par par beaucoup de public
différent pas seulement publics
américains ou allemands ou français mais
pas vraiment toutes les personnes parce
que faut pas oublier que arnold
schwazenegger nous dit qu'il n'a pas
participé lui-même à des projections
tests du film pour voir comment les gens
réagissaient mais de toute façon il sait
il sent il sait très bien que le film va
être grâce à cette dimension
humoristique va être compris et apprécié
par des gens partout dans le monde qui
soit en chine en france ou dans
n'importe quel coin du monde
et par rapport à cela jean claude van
damme nous dit que sa position à lui est
légèrement différente parce que dans le
film lui c'est le sait le méchant c'est
le bas de gamme et est donc lui c'était
aussi peint ce conte son côté héroïque
c'était de trouver quelqu un quelque
chose contre qui se battre et il nous
dit que jouer ce rôle pour sylvester
stallone c'était vraiment quelque chose
de formidable parce que sylvester
stallone a trouvé tous ces petits
moments magiques pour pour eux pour
pouvoir vraiment brillé entre guillemets
à l'écran il a vraiment donné la
possibilité à chaque comédien du film à
tous les comédiens du film non pas
d'être entre guillemets un peu noyé dans
la vente dans tout le casting certes
prestigieux mais vraiment pour chaque
personne d'avoir la possibilité de
s'exprimer de briller à l'écran à un
moment donné et chacun entre guillemets
chacun a sa chance et donc tous les
comédiens du film ont eu ce petit moment
où ils ont pu briller comme ça l'un
après l'autre et c'était quelque chose
de formidable et d'ailleurs jean claude
van damme nous dit quelque chose
formidable qui sans aucun doute en tout
cas avec un casting comme celui là ne se
renouvellera sur grand écran et enfin
nous dit il par rapport à la définition
du héros pour lui et bien c'est
quelqu'un qui certes fait des choses
héroïque qui dans ce cas précis par
exemple doit se battre mais c'est aussi
quelqu'un qui a peur de se battre et qui
n'a p qui n'a pas peur de montrer qu'il
a peur de se baptiser il a peur il ya il
ya une appréhension mais il va quand
même se battre pour pouvoir accomplir
ces choses héroïque et voilà c'était un
petit peu les les différentes
définitions du mot héros pour les
comédiens ici aujourd'hui une autre
question au premier oui alors je vais la
faire courte
vous devrez depuis des décennies vous
maintenir en forme
vous pouvez pas vraiment vous laisser
aller est ce qu'il n'ya pas des moments
où c'est particulièrement épuisants et
contraignant
m steyn shape and some
entité
810 aux importations
en fait lorsque moi même je vais
m'entraîner je j'exige j'hésite toujours
entre ce sont des expressions anglaises
donc c'est une traduction approximative
entre entre super bons coups alors me
reposer un bon coup
ces
bateaux
et de
so we
still
walking dead
nation
sort au revoir au 10 juillet we know
about the world as we know how do so
enjoy un peu des
deux
y est
en fête
sylvester stallone ne dit que la
question qu'on se pose toujours lorsque
lorsqu'on doit s'entraîner et rester en
forme et rester en en bon état physique
et pouvoir continuer à faire ce genre de
choses pendant pendant longtemps c'est
le plaisir est ce que le plaisir en vaut
la chandelle par rapport à la douleur
aussi la douleur la difficulté que l'on
a justement à rester en forme dans ce
genre de forme et il nous dit que pour
lui en tout cas pour toutes les
personnes qui ont participé à ce film la
réponse est clairement oui c'est le jeu
en vaut la chandelle parce que bien sûr
c'est difficile bien sûr ne pas faire
très attention à ce qu'on mange
s'entraîner énormément que ce soit en
salle de musculation en salle de sport
c'est évidemment quelque chose de
difficile mais on en retire un vrai
plaisir et on continue d'en retirer un
vrai plaisir et quelque part c'est aussi
cette discipline dans laquelle il trouve
du plaisir et il nous dit que
aujourd'hui lui et ses coéquipiers ils
connaissent leur corps très très bien il
savait exactement comment faire ils
connaissent les bons gestes et les
bonnes méthodes et les bonnes techniques
donc ils savent comment faire mais cela
prend du temps beaucoup de temps des
années avant d'arriver à vraiment savoir
la meilleure chose à faire les bonnes
les bonnes méthodes les bons les bons
gestes et voilà mes mais encore une fois
il le dit la réponse est oui si le jeu
en vaut la chandelle mais oui c'est
également très très difficile une autre
question dans la salle
pennington
ecstasy
délit training
expérience de plage
ping chef
éric
ce
ne soit
pas
à la hauteur
news corp est
implacable et
du mouv et de lactate de diqing
onuci devait abdomen
mr l'homme manifestement
un autre must gc midi ils continuaient à
s'affronter
news on a fait un bon match à neuf
willocq vers yang we need is de ce lac
fqu jennings was
so when we go anti-vih au rang
des
chaînes et trois touchés de troubles dys
et d'oise easy way une scène et ne
savent non à
12h27
chapeau
bas
à magic mc drive
jusqu'au lundi 6 à
talons alice baisse
de
10,9 à liesberg
à lausanne
lorsqu'on lorsqu'on s'entraîne lorsqu'on
fait des entraînements pour pouvoir
rester fort rester en reste et en bonne
forme physiquement pendant très
longtemps en fait cela devient très
rapidement une véritable addiction c'est
quelque chose auquel lui-même nous dit
par exemple qu'il ne peut pas imaginer
passer une semaine sans s'entraîner sans
aller à la salle pour la salle de sport
pour s'entraîner et quelque part il nous
dit que tous ces rôles qu'ils ont fait
ça a également beaucoup contribué à
promouvoir le fitness l'entraînement le
fait de prendre soin de soi il nous dit
qu'il ya quelques années en fait il
était impossible de trouver une salle de
sport dans certains hôtels certains
hôtels en afrique par exemple ou
ailleurs et aujourd'hui on a des on a
évidemment des salles de sport dans tous
les hôtels et il nous dit que parfois il
y à même d équipement sportif parfois
même de très haut niveau très
sophistiqué dans les chambres
directement donc quelque part il est
assez content de voir cette évolution
pour pouvoir continuer à être en forme
et s'occuper de soi
et il le dit pour lui le sport c'est
quelque chose de presque naturel c'est
comme lorsqu'on mange c'est comme
lorsqu'on dort c'est comme lorsqu'on
fait l'amour c'est quelque chose tout ça
quelque part ça peut tout tous et toutes
ces choses sondés sont des choses qui
peuvent être perçus comme étant
s'entraîner prendre soin de soi c'est
s'exercer et c'est resté rester au top
et aimé pour lui il nous dit que c'est
pas du tout quelque chose de
contraignant c'est un style de vie et
c'est le sien notamment il nous dit que
par exemple ce matin ils ont pris des
vélos six vélos ils sont partis visiter
paris comme ça en vélo tout simplement
pour pouvoir passer du temps ils ne se
font pas ils ne se sont pas posé la
question est ce que savait difficile
contraignant de faire du vélo non au
contraire ils sont partis visiter paris
comme ça le matin et ils ont vu cette
cette ville magnifique en vélo ce qui
est une manière très agréable de
découvrir paris est quelque part ne lit
lorsqu'il des jeunes lorsqu'il dort
lorsqu'il prend son petit déjeuner voilà
il n'ya pas une discipline particulière
à faire ces choses assez naturel et bien
pour lui s'entraîner faire du sport et
se maintenir en forme c'est pareil c'est
quelque chose de naturel en tout cas
c'est quelque chose qui ne lui viendrait
pas à l'idée de se passer de ce verrou
choses et jean claude van damme ajoute
que en même temps c'est vrai que lorsque
lorsqu'on les regarde on voit sur leurs
visages qui disons qu'ils ont souffert
entre guillemets que ça a été difficile
parfois de s'entraîner pendant toutes
ces années pour pouvoir rester rester au
top physiquement mais quelque part ils
ont ils ont besoin de ça c'est quelque
chose c'est un serveur et besoins en
hausse et ils ne prennent pas ça du tout
comme une contrainte particulière et
c'est vrai que jean claude lise et
notamment parfois la télévision
lorsqu'on nous poser que ce genre de
question est-ce que c'est difficile et c
est bien on a envie de répondre oui
c'est vrai c'est difficile c'est
contraignant mais en même temps non pour
eux c'est pas si difficile que ça parce
que c'était facile quelque part s'il
aime faire ça ça fait vraiment partie de
leur personnalité et de leur routine
quotidienne
donc il nous dit que ça ça n'a pas été
très difficile par contre nous
rappelle-t-il parfois sur le tournage
arriver à l'heure au moment du tournage
ça parfois ça a été un tout petit peu
plus difficile mais s'entraîner restants
mais
évidemment avec la bague est toujours
très près de la main mais en tout cas en
tout cas dans s'entraîner faire du sport
c'est ça fait vraiment partie de leur
style de vie et et dolph lundgren
d'ailleurs nous rappelle quelque chose
qu'il avait dit tout à l'heure et que je
n'avais pas traduit qui était que dans
quelques minutes tout à l'heure ce que
dans quelques minutes tout à l'heure
d'ailleurs il faut qu'il aille enfin il
faut il doit aller à la salle de sport
pour s'entraîner il va y aller il ya
ilahi la hâte d'y être et jean-claude la
terminer en présentant quelques dessins
réalisés par les comédiens ici présents
qui sont d'ailleurs vendus aux enchères
dans quelques temps des efforts des
dessins un merveilleux que vous pourrez
découvrir dans la galerie du georges 5 à
n'en pas douter dans quelques jours
voilà et s'est terminée cette conférence
de presse c'est fini merci beaucoup cinq
nouvelles images